Hello, Everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Doom.
Now there's some story here, right here
"Olivia Pierce, the cult leader of the UAC is trying to open a gateway into their dimension..."
So first off: I WAS RIGHT!!! *shock*
There is a frickin' cult aspect of this organization, *quick intake of air* and I don't know why every single thing in the future
turns into a cult eventually... It happens in Dead Space, it happens in a LOT of other games...
But anyway, "She wants to help bring about the end of this world. Another lost soul fallen under Hell's control."
"Olivia overclocked the Argent Tower, using it to drill a hole into the Hellscape and let Hell's army through."
"You need to shut down the Argent Tower before it breaks through into their world..."
"by disabling the energy filters located throughout the surface complex."
So, my guess... Thee arr- the Argent Tower is some way to harness the energy of Hell...
To be able to use it for our own purposes.
And that was kind of the point of this Mars facility.          Samuel Hayden: Olivia is using the tower to drill a hole into the doorway into their world.
Samuel Hayden: You can prevent her from opening the gate by disabling the tower's induction filters.
Okay. That's cool. I'ma da do that and that'll be really nice. Uhh...
But the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna upgrade my weapons.
I'ma gonna hold off on upgrading this because I want one more token to be able to find the security buzzing feature.
Which is very nice, I suppose.
But anyway, I want...
"Can be fired indefinitely without requiring a reload" that sounds awesome!
But I wanna do something here because I need a little bit more...
*completely loses train of thought*
Oh that would be nice!
"Removing the loading time for an explosive shot" because that, that was kind of annoying in that...
If I want to blow something up with this, I want to just be able to just switch to it and then BLOW it up right away.
So that's going to be a little bit of a benefit to me.
I am low *brain farts* on ammo across the board, so someone is about to get CHAINSAWED!
Who wants to be a volunteer!?
*crazily* I have a lot of chainsaw to share with you guys. Anybody? Any takers?
no?
No?
Alright. FINE.
UAC Spokesperson: Untethered crossdimensional activity is a frequent occurrence outside of the base.
UAC Spokesperson: So it is recommended that workers buddy up when journeying onto the Martian surface.
UMMM... "Untethered crossdimensional activity" sounds a whole lot like...
Demons crawling out of a gaping butthole in the universe and fucking up some SHIT!
*sniffs*
If I had to guess about what that means, that's probably the documented way to say that properly.
Probably the official "language guidelines" way to say that.
Yep! Seems like some demons fucked up some shit over here!
It's a good thing I've got my Master's Degree in Fucking Shit Up™ as well.
Ooh! That looks nice. What is that?
Can I shoost that?
Can I bleuw that up?
(YES YOU CAN!)
What is happening?
What's with all the automated things going on? And also how is Olivia surviving through this?
I mean, I get that she's probably possessed by the demons, and they're influencing her behavior...
But at the same time, I'm kind of curious to see... how they're letting her live considering the...
Proclivity of demons fighting each otherness.
Okay. I can't go up that way.
Alright. Let us venture forth like a boss.
Wherever the hell we want to venture.
UMMM. Yeah, okay. Fine by me.
Where am I going? Please tell m- Ooh! Is this a secret? I wanna find a secret!
Doesn't look like a secret. :(
Ah! It's not a secret!
Whenever they just put armor underneath a platform like that, it's never qualified as a secret.
Why not go a little deeper and be able to do something else with it?
I don't know.
I'm just complaining for the sake of complaining at this point.
HYUP!
HYUP-DE-POOP-DE
BYUP-DE-FYUP
Anybody?
Anybody else?
*screams* PYUP!
Okay. *Demons snarling*
Oh no!
De-Mons! Oh, they're above me. Heryup!
Boink. Okay.
What is you?
You look interesting. I'm gonna touch you!
"Rune Trial?"
Cooooool!
Nice!
I'm down with that! "Fifteen (15) Imps before the timer expires?"
Yeah, I wanna do that! HOT SHIT!
Heh...
*amused* There's just random portals into Hell to be able to be like, "Hey! Hey, Doom guy! You're familiar with this Hellscape...
Why don't you do this little challenge here."
Alright, I'ma do this. Hell yeah, I can do this!
Fuck yeah! Bring it on, bruh!
With a shotgun? Easy-peasy-lemon-squeeze me!
Uhuh.
Do I have a charge burst or anything? No?
No?
Stop it. >:(
Let's do this. It'll give me more time.
Yeah. I'm pretty sure it gives me like, four (4) seconds per Glory Kill.
There we go. There we go.
boop
Hyup. Okay.
Boink.
K
Uhuh. How many kills I got? Enough!
Pleeenty of kills! This is eeeeeeasy. Aww it's child's play.
And finally, I get the range that I can absorb dropped items because that was a problem.
Uh - If there were health drops from me meleeing something, sometimes they just spray all over the place...
And I wouldn't be able to pick them up, and that's a bit of a problem when I'm trying to not DIE.
'Cause I need that health.
'Cause I'm bad.
But anyway, that's a different *stutters*
*old man dying noise*
Runes?
I didn't even know I had runes. What is this? Diablo 3? Holy shit.
Okay.
B'okay. I'm okay with that. I didn't even know that was an option!
So cool.
Hey, come back here. I have a bone to pick with yoOOou.
Where'd you go?!
What a little baby!
*Scottish accent* What ta little whining baaaby!
Oh, ya sweet little bahby.
Okay.
Umm...
Seems like there would be something over here that I would need to be able to jump up on but apparently not...
Nothing down there. Nothing that I can see, anyway.
Hyup!
Alrighty then. I guess that's it. Carrying on!
(Hello, Darkness, my old friend)
This seems like a trap!
HUH. I love what you've done with the place! Your decorations are delightful!
That was another thing in the original Doom...
Like, there was a lot of stuff in the background that I didn't actually notice the first time that I played around...
But in like, the last chapter, uh, I think, or The Shores of Hell, I can't remember which one it was...
But there was like, people that were strung up on the walls, and it freaked me the frick out...
I would like, stare at them. But like, an' just... marveling at the grossness that was in fronta me.
OOH!
I know what that is!
*New toy acquired*
That's the rocket launcher! HELL YEAH!
I love the way that Doom approaches the rocket launcher.
You get like, fifty (50) rockets, but in this case you get five (5) rockets, shoot them as fast as you can...
No reloading, hell yeah, go blow up some shit. And that's the way that rockets should be handled.
But the other thing that I was talking about is... they did a lot... with very little in the original Doom.
Because if you think about the computer limitations back then, like...
Hooly shit!
It was looow.
That guy survived a rocket blast?
Ohhhh. Hello.
Boink!
Good thing I got also rockets on this.
Ohh not that one. >:(
I don't want that involved.
Give me the frickin'- *Marki-pup howl* - K
Gonna throw this there.
Hyup!
No.
I- Woah..
*Sudden realization*
He's dead!?
*shock* I dunno wh- I-I didn't do it.
I didn't do it ;-;
aaAAH shiet
Doink!
Okay.
*girly screams fill the air*
Boink!
That guy spawned into death immediately. So did that guy.
Yoink! Thank you - Woah - my goodness...
It-It's just interesting because sometimes it'll be a very violent one out of nowhere.
And occasionally it'll be, the you know, the happy fun-time one.
The one where everyone's just so joyously fli-frolicking around as I beat the ever-living shit out of 'em.
Can I do this from the above thing?
WOAH-HO-WOAH
Y-y-you-your you're not one that frolics.
Y-you-you're... I am the one that frolics. Holy shit.
boink.
Oh, boy.
This is kinda cool.
HABAHDA
Ohp. You're dead?
Really?
You dead?
You're dead?!
WHAT?!
How'd you die?!
I didn't do that!
That guy's weaker than I thought he was. Oh well.
His loss!
I mean, he lost his life, but he was a demon so what does that really mean?
HOUP
Okay.
Huh.
Maybe I missed out on like, the double-jump boots because there seem to be some like...
Areas around here that require double-jump, but I can't seem to get to them.
And I didn't know - like, where? Maybe the yellow button - maybe the yellow thing was just like a...
Oh. Wait. Nevermind.
No? Not up there?
Dammit.
Up there?
No?
Dammit.
Oh, hello.
Come back!
COME BACK!
Come back, you bitch! COME BACK!
You little...
asshole.
Oh, they're fighting again. Don't know why.
What is going on over there?
They're in some kind of a war.
I-It's like a war between the Demons and the Possessed dudes...
And for some reason they don't like each other very much.
Which is fine by me. I mean, I don't care. What am I supposed to be able do with that?
So, I'm guessing that these - these like, Hell Spawn things are what's bridging the two worlds together...
And eventually... it's going to quote-unquote "bring about the end of the world."
Which is... you know... pretty cool.
I mean, it's-it's pretty rad.
I-I mean, I'm not down with it, but whatever. I can't exactly control the universe.
You're gonna go crazy if you try to control everything around you.
'Scuse me. Coming to say hi. Hello!
bup
Another one?
Man, these guys just crawl out of the woods don't they?
HABAHDAHHABAHDAHHABADAH
WOAH. Hey, buddy.
You dead yet?
You dead?
You are now.
Thank you!
Wow. I'll just miss a whole bunch, why don't I.
youp
K-okay.
I heard something else.
HOUP.
Haha!
He got esploded into a bajillion pieces.
*fangirls* Rockets. YES.
"Weapon Upgrade Point." Umm.
I need to be able to get that thing because I want to upgrade the rocket launcher.
But I don't know where that little doofus went off to.
Maybe I missed my chance to be able to get up to him, but I don't think that would be true.
Something else up here.
Hello!
OH, COME ON.
There we go. That's what I thought.
HYUP!
Please tell me this is a secret and not just the way I'm supposed to be able to- GOD DAMMIT.
I keep thinking that I'm going up to secrets here, but apparently NOT. *demon screams in agony*
*imitates Demon scream*
Hey, can I do this?
Hey, can I sa- WOAH. That's- I didn't mean to spawn inside you, buddy.
WOAH.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
I'm out. I'm out, baby. I'm outtie!
HUAAAHHH
Wh-who's coming after me?
Oh! You are!
The exact one that I wanted to talk to!
Okay, and... there we go.
Got you! Okay.
boop
Oh, another one. Jeezums!
These guys are coming outta the walls!
WOAH!
No thank you.
WOAH. GAH, GOD DAMMIT. AH, FUCK YOU.
WOAH-WA-HEY-WAAAY boink.
Well.
That was unpleasant on my end.
It was bound to happen eventually. I was being a bit of a dick and I think that I actually only...
Blew myself up a little bit with my shotgun explosive. But!
I'll get back into it. Don't worry about it. It's cool.
Alright. At least I'm back here and in a relatively close place where to where I was before.
Ah! There was my problem! I didn't armor up before I went up there.
And also, I - there was probably a different way I could have gone.
I wonder if results in more or less enemies. Oh.
Well, I'm not going to do that! Screw, you guys!
I'm going to go the shortcut that I originally intended to go, and you guys are all going to suck dong!
Because I'm awesome and you're not.
Not you guys! You guys are way more awesome than I am, so forget that!
heh
I wish- I wish the p- Maybe I should upgrade the pistol.
I haven't done th- Is the pistol even upgradable?
I have no idea because it's the only thing with unlimited ammo.
And I mean it is a bit of a wimpy bitch gun, but that doesn't matter as much. I don't care about that.
come on
Ehh! There we go! Huppp!
okay
Who wants to fiiiight?
I know a lot of people do... *demon screams in agony*
Boink. Okay. Where's the big guy? Woah...this doesn't seem happy.
Whoop. Okay
Let me go back up to my perch.
I'm actually able to do some damage.
Come on!
Thaat's what I thought.
HOOUP
Gonna get ahead of the curve here.
Tired of playing the long game.
Woop. Okay. I'm actually out of everything, aren't I?
SHIT!
I made a mistake! Aah!
Aaaahh!
I think... I think I can get this guy with this.
YEEEAAAHH!
I CAN!
*laughs* I get so much ammo from it!
HELL YEEEAAAHH!
bomp
Okay, that guy's dead.
You're gonna be dead.
Whoop. Thank you.
That...
Okay. That guy's dead.
All good in this neighborhood. Okay, we're good.
Alright. Actually, I'm going to do something here because I think that I've been playing this game a little bit too dark?
Because... I can't actually see anything.
I'm gonna just increase the...
Gamma a bit to see if that actually does something to help me see.
OH THAT'S SO MUCH BETTER!
I CAN ACTUALLY SEE, AND YOU GUYS PROBABLY CAN ACTUALLY SEE!
OH THAT'S WAY BETTER!
Maybe just one (1) notch down because... it's a little too much.
Maybe one-point-two (1.2). That should be better.
My god, I've been playing BLIND!
OH THAT'S WAY BETTER!
What have I been doing? I haven't even been able to appreciate anything.
Oh, that's so much better. I'mma doof.
I'm a big doofy-doo.
That's okay. I'm your doofy-doo, and that's all that matters. <3
Samuel Hayden: We are only temporarily disabling the Tower; you need to remove each lens individually.
Samuel Hayden: Carefully release the hinges...
YEAH! WAH! That's what I'm talking about.
Facility Voice: Warning. Energy contamination detected.
Uhuh.
Samuel Hayden: *bitterly* Destroying the production of Argent Energy isn't necessary.
Ummm..
*sassy markimoo arises*  Maybe go screw yourself?
Everyone at this facility is kinda dead already.
So maybe you can  just shove it up your butt hole!
And let me do my job! How about that???
I still gotta find where the hell that one little guy went.
I know he's around here somewhere...
He's gotta be around here.
He went...
Did he go - He went right here didn't he?!
I gotta find this guy...
GIVE GIVE GIVE GIVE GIVE!!
Where are you!!
WHERE ARE YOU!?
Someone down here??? Someone hiding from me??
HHuuuhhh???
YA YOU WENT DOWN HERE!
SWEET! *somewhat raspy voice* Give me this shit!
Ooh remote det- *GASP*
YEAHHHHH *weaponsgasm*
Hmm..
Ooh
Me likey.
Marky LIKE.
Mmm
Yeah I like that, that's, I like that a lot.
Excuse me, thank you.
You should just give that to me nicely. Instead of making me chase you down
Okay, so now I got a lock-on feature.
I actually totally forgot that I had the rocket launcher.
In my moment of panic when I had no weapons or ammo
I kinda forgot that I had the option to do this stuff
But oh well, you live and learn then you get loves
not sponsored by loves
ok
Hello? PUNCH
lemme just punch that in the face
I solve all my problems by punching it very hard in the face
WOOP. OW. My knees.
Do I even have knees? Do I even need knees?
Am I human enough to need anything remotely-
WOAH. NICE!
BOINK
Sorry but how are you still alive after that?
I'll take that- is this not a secret?
DAMMIT
But I think I got enough armor tokens to be able to get the secret vibration device
That's something completely different-
We're not unlocking the secret vibration device, we're just gonna-
We're gonna PULSATE when we're near secrets so that'll be good.
"Full View: explore the AutoMap automatically."
Okay... Oh, maybe I should've been looking at the map? *the internet collectively facepalms*
Ohh that would've been MUCH better!
Ohh this- OHH!
I didn't know this was here.
Well then. I... am stupid.
Ah. Oh, Elite Guards, that's the thing that have the Praetor Tokens.
Ohhh.
Okay.
Alright.
That makes more sense.
Ah...
Okay.
Alright, I can use this information, I haven't been looking at the map enough.
How many of you guys out there were really pissed that I wasn't looking at the map?
And then I was complaining about everything not being where I thought it was gonna be?
My apologies for that, I was being a bit doofy on that front.
But I'll be better next time, don't you worry about that, so...
I believe up there...
Or at least up here in this area up here...
There is some sort of aah - houp...
There's a secret up here - No, over there.
Ah, over there. How do I get over there?
Should be directly across..
Huh
I think up there.
I'm not 100% on this because I'm still a little disoriented on where I'm going but...
I'll get back to that in a second because...
I want to explore the area fully and there might be another way around over this way.
Hello, what are you?
Hi buddy. Bu-ddy
Ok, fine. BEH. There we go.
Yeh-BOINK
OK. That's one down.
Ahh, screw you, guys.
Umm through here? Hello!
MUSCLE ᕙ། ಠ 益 ಠೃ །ᕗ
Okay.. Anybody around?
HAA-*fart*
Thank you.
Little confuzzled as to the layout.
Okay, nevermind then, apparently this is just a dead-end too.
Alright, I'm coming down.
Everybody still alive around here? No?
Alright then. Fine, be that way.
Another...
"UAC Personnel Vega." Okay.
Oh, I have two Vega?
"Takes a lot of power"... "head of UAC"...
OHH... He's an autonomous artificial intelligence, okay.
Well, I didn't KNOW that about Vega. I had a sneaking suspicion that he was some sorta computer...
But I didn't know that he was actually a fully-fledged artificial intelligence.
That's awfully nice.
Okay. So if I had to... pull up the map...
I am very near whatever the hell that is.
Okay, I don't know where this secret is, uh.
But I'm not gonna be spending my time too much running around in circles.
[Dr. Samuel Dildo over helmet comm]
Uhh. It seems like I don't give a shit about your stupid hell-energy.
Samuel Hayden: *angrily* What you are destroying is more valuable than you can possible imagine.
Samuel Hayden: It is a perfect and unlimited energy resource.
See, that's what you're saying, but I saw it.
It was red on one side, blue on the other.
And now it's all red.
I only see blood. My eyes are literally filled with blood. Demon blood specifically.
So you think I care? The answer would be no.
I feel like there's a way up here because it seems to me...
That I am directly above something but *vaguely German accent?* that does not matter.
Ok. Whatever, I'm gonna carry on.
'Cause I got nothing better to do with my time.
So, I'm just gonna follow my waypoints and hopefully it's gonna pulsate.
When I'm near a secret because it hasn't been doing that before, but whatever.
Whatevs, bruh.
It's fine.
So I gotta get up there.
HUP
Whoops, I went the wrong way around.
Oopsy doopsy.. Maybe over here?
*sings* HELLO!
This seems like a new area that I haven't been before.
Facility Voice: Demon breach detected.
OOoh it's very BLUE.
You wanna die bruh?
Boink, apparently.
Hey buddy.. Ahh
Whoops missed him.
HAAP
HO- whoops, HOHP. JEP
I'm just missing everybody that I'm intending to hit.
This is quite stupid.
HEHP
Ow again with the- WOAH not you!
Goddammit I hate you!
There we go- BOINK! Okay. Now we're back into it.
BOINK- Ok got you, get you done.
Break your arm because you probably cared about that.
This guy's deeead...
Pull this outta heeere...
Get my rocket launcher out. Prepare for the Hell Knights!
BEHHH- boink
Sorry.
Anybody wanna play?
Anybody wanna have some fun tonight?
BOINK
UH OH- whoops. Didn't need to hit you with three (3).
I need to to hit YOU with three (3).
BOINK
Fight me.
Fight me, bruh.
Fight. Fight me.
Boink.
Fight me.
Thank you.
Boink.
*laughs* That guy - That guy's day just got messed up to an amazing degree.
hip
hup
Boink. Okay.
Alright. God dammit. Son of a bitch.
There is probably another Hell Knight's on the way somewhere, but I just don't know whe-
THAT SOUNDS LIKE HE'S RIGHT NEAR ME!
Oh, nevermind then. Apparently I was very wrong.
I thought I heard him.
huh
Oh no, it's just you guys. Okay.
Alright. Fine by me, you cowardly bastards.
Anybody else?
Wooaah. What is that?
Again, I'm getting this way too - wooOOOHHH.
I'm going moderately faster than I was before!
Not a lot faster, thank you very much.
But moderately. You know, a decent speed.
Not too fast to be dangerous.
Spine break. ༼ง=ಠ益ಠ=༽ง
Whoops.
Okay, anybody else?
This haste sure is going to waste.
*sarcastically* Glad I got this.
Greaaattt. Just gonna get this here.
*sing song* Thank youuuu!
Hmm. I'm doing wonderfully.
I'm doing absolutely wonderfully.
I'm making everybody at home proud of me. Aren't you proud of me guys?
Aren't you proud of what I'm doing here? (Always, Mark.)
The amazing work that I'm doing... *trails off as Facility voice butts in over P.A.*
*fart noise* Alright.
So that's broken. Then he's probably still pissed off at me.
*reading info* Monsters: Hell Knight? I know! I've been killing them A LOT!
Okay. *reading*
-wait. By the Guardian?
Wait a minute.
*deep contemplation derp face*
*confuzzled* Ahhh?
*excited* Am I the Guardian?!
Is that who they call him?!
Not Doom guy?
I think it's Doo- it's gotta be Doom guy.
It's GOTTA be Doom guy.
It wouldn't- It wouldn't NOT be Doom guy.
Huh.
That's...in-tre-sting.
I didn't even know that that was there.
auhhhhh...
Okay! Alright then.
So I need to find the rest of the elite guards because I didn't realize that the- WOAHHH! WHAT'RE YOU?!?!?
Oh, I don't know what you are!
I remember there was, uh, there was a monster in the original Doom that definitely summoned other demons.
So don't be doin' that crap!
Woah! Woah, woah, woah!
How bout I lock onto ya, ya biiIITCCCHHH!
Oh no, you  dieeddddd.
Ohoho nohoho!
I'm not sorry at all.
Hup! Thank you.
Anybody else? Huh? Anybody else?
I sure am glad that I got this lock on technique because otherwise that wouldn've been a bit of a bitchhh.
But I'm very smart and proactive about what I do!
[Dr. Samuel Shitlark over the helmet comm]
Mark: *unimpressed* Uh-huh.
[Dr. Samuel Dick continues circle jerking himself]
Um, you kinda unleashed me, dude, and you kinda just trusted that I would just follow your directions. I mean,
that's kinda your my mistake there, not really mine.
There's an elite guard up there how did I miss that?
See that's the problem. I don't exactly know the... precise layout of where I've been and where I'm going.
because these are all- seem to be in very secluded areas. But that definitely seems like someplace that I have been.
Hmm. If I get back outside that's just gonna take me to the end. I gotta go back.
I do have to go back, otherwise I'm not going to have any upgrades.
Oh okay up here the-Ohhhhhh
Right here I almo-I probably missed you I probably saw this guy
I just didn't like do anything about it
Thank you for fighting the good fight and failing miserably
Let me take your power and then make it my own
Okay so I got another one of those but I'm not gonna do that just yet because I want...
To find the others...Like the other guy over here on the other side. Okay
I'm gonna find him
(Quiet) Wherever he may be.
How long has that been there?
How long have I missed that? *barely audible* I don't know.
Doesn't matter. Gonna get it now.
Oooh. Maybe up here? Was it up here?
*Gasp*
I think it might have been up here.
(Sing song) HELLLOO HI.
You're dead can I have this? Thank you. See this is why I go back. This is why I actually check my map.
This is why I think about things before I do them.
(Mean) Do you think I got anywhere on youtube BY THINKING!?
(Meaner) BEFORE DOING!?
(Calm) No the answer is no. Anyway nowwww.
Got those.
The only Elite Guard left is one in front.
Of the way that I'm going
If I could ever find that little guy.
Which I cannot.
So, if I go above, which I've done before,
I should be able to find that rune. And then I get another rune.
And also, I don't know how long that's been there, but I haven't taken care of that.
I should probably.
Heeuuh whatever.
Aha! Over here! Yes, please, yes!
Yes, please! Thank you!
*reading* "Armed with the pistol, destroy 30 barrels before the timer expires."
Okay! I'm fine with that! Sounds easy!
I'm good with shooting things, in the face, and blowing them...up.
*pops lips* *quietly* Anyway.
Ok! Let's do this! Boinga boom.
Hap! OHH! These aren't barrels! These are, these are boxes of skulls!
Why the- Why am me do this?
Why am- Also, why in hell do they think convenient barrels are just skulls all lumped together?
I don't know, whatever.
It's not me, I didn't do it.
Whoops shit, I missed.
Oh shit, I gotta find the barrels.
Dammit! Uh-oh! UH-oh!
Oh good, thank you for that.
That's very helpful. GODDAMIT!
*high pitched* Ahh! Get it!
Get it! Get it! Gettt it! *cry of victory* YAHHHHH! Just barely.
*laughs* I didn't even see where they were until the last second. Thank goodness that it got that.
I didn't even see what the reward was gonna be.
I just did because I'm a badaaasss. Just like everything I do in this game.
Just like everything Doom guy ever does in his entire life. He only does it cuz he's an *western voice* utter badass.
Which is fine.
*reading* Each mission has a secret that unlocks a classic Doom map. If you find one it can be played by visiting the classic maps menu.
That sounds awesome! Too bad I don't find very many secrets because I'm a big dumb doofy doo.
Okay, what did I get?
"Increases how long demons remain in a stagger state." Ahhh, that y'know, that seems fine.
Cuz they already stay in a stagger state pretty long and,
they-they stay around long enough for me to just destroy them anyway. So I don't think it matters too much.
Oh, Hello!
What're you doin' here?
What're ya'll doin'?
Hello! See they stay quite a long time.
Thank you.
Can you not!? Whoevers doing that over there, can you just not thank you.
Whoa. Hoho. (almost Santa)
That guy didn't have a lot left of him.
Allright thank youuu.
I need this for my collection please. (kinky)
Stop screaming you big baby-Whoa who did that?
WHOA- who? Wooaahhh wait! Whoa, wait whoa.
(light scream) Aghhh I got hit by one thing
Apparently...And there's a big hole in my chest.
Ahhh whatever. Okay ignore that
"Dont't" know how that happened
Uhhhhh probbably my own fault, if I had to guess,
If I had to warrant a guess into anything that happened there,
It was probably entirely my own fault.
Okay, take twa.
Ooh
Boink. whoa.
No, thank you. Boink. Ok, there we go.
Whoa not you,
Not you (x2)
Not you (x3)
Eghhh.
Hup.
Whoa. God dammit jus-Whoa why can't I fucking hit this guy
Whoa why was that guy so hard to hit?
Hup a dup
No
No (x2)
No (x3)
No (x4)
No (x5)
No (x6)
Nooo (x7)
NOOOO (x8)
NOOOOO (x9)
Oh yes please, thank you.
Raghhh. Got you down.
Whoa there was a- I thought I saw a big guy around but apparently I was a lying liar.
Oh, it would've been convenient if I would've seen that demon upgrade over here.
This probably would have helped me incredibly if I had gotten that while I was fighting everybody.
But no! I'm a dumb-dumb.
I'm not gonna do that because I'm horrendously stupid.
Okay, but I can't find it.
*barely audible* Oh, well.
Grabbin' this. *sarcastically* Oh, boy a berserk pack! This is really helpful at the moment!
[U.A.C. Spokesperson over P.A.]
Mark: The twelve council of nine? Is that different from the silent council? There's seeming to be a lot of council members here!
[Dr. Samuel still spouting bullshit over helmet comm]
Mark: Okay! Sounds good to me!
WHU-BUFF!
WHU-BUMF!
AGGHGHRRRGH-BOINK!
Cooolll. Niceee.
Wellll doneee.
[Dr. Samuel Cliche over helmet comm]
Mark: Yes, I do! You just explained it to me!
[VEGA over helmet comms]
Mark: Huh. Okay. That sounds promising.
[Dr. Samuel Liar Pants over helmet comm]
Mark: Ummm, no. I think I've got other objectives that I can have.
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna go after this Olivia Pierce person,
and it's gonna be super fun times when I run into her and we're gonna have a nice tea party, and we're gonna do all *brain fart* all sorts of cool stuff together.
It's gonna be good.
It's gonna be good. (x2)
I don't know what an Argent Cell is... I found no secrets?! God, I'm such a fool. I even got the upgrade where things pulse!
But I don't know what the pulsation is!
Wahhh! *reading* "Against Samuel Hayden's wishes you stopped production of Argent *burps* energy, and delayed the pell-hell portal from opening."
"Still determined to bring the armies of hell to this dimension, Olivia Pierce has taken an accumulator to the top of the Argent Tower and plans to use it to open a transdimensional rift,"
"blowing open a portal into their world."
"This cannot happen. *deep voice* You must kill Olivia Pierce."
I must stop her from blowing these portals all over the place!
Man, she just is a rampant blower!
(That's what he said.)
Cool...
*reads* "Kill Olivia Pierce"
Well that's a rather blatant a- like objective that I have.
Oooh
Okay, something down there - I think that's- must be the map
Or at least that's what I think that is.
So I'm gonna go get that - ooh, hello.
Who's doin th-
Oh, hello! I know yooou!
You're- you're a revenant, aren't you?
I think that's the name of it... revenant? (Yes it is.)
Woah.
Hey buddy!
Woah, these guys are kinda tough.
Uegh, that doesn't seem good.
You wanna f- I'ma- I'm gonna miss.
See - I- I don't actually wanna hit ya.
*high pitched* Poink!
Oh noo! You're dead!
How 'bout that?
Okay
Soo.. there's gotta be a way...
*increasing in pitch* Uuuup?
No?
'Parently not.
(Is) there anything on my map?
Nah just the rune over there but I gotta be able to get in that room somehow...
*inhales* I just dunno how.
Boink!
Hmm.
Oh well.
*talking loudly* I'll figure it out, don't worry.
What (are you) doing?
Hey, get those needles outta mah face!
He's peppering me with something... unimportant and stupid.
Can I kill this guy? How much - jeezums
Guy's too stronk.
Heeep
'Kay.
What is that gonna do-
OH I just kick him into the other people.
That's... that's probably good.
Woah, what the - WHAT?!
WHAT!? (x2)
What the fuck!?
Well that's stupid.
Hep!
Gimme your... hey pretty lady!
Habedabep!
Oh no, he deaded.
Hep!
Ohhhmm.. direct hit.
Boink! I don't wanna deal with you.
Woah was that another one?
Hey buddy!
Babadeboop!
Oh no, he ahsploded!
Oh well, too bad for him.
Boink!
Boink... (x2)
Boink. (x3)
Okay!
What else do we got?
Facility Voice: Demonic presence eliminated. Lockdown disengaged.
Mark: Anybody?
*high pitched* D'okay!
[UAC Spokesperson over P.A.]
*low pitched* D- ooooooooh!
Mark: I don't care! I just got the double jump boots
which means that I'ma gitto-go heppedihoppedi all the way to the candy shopy.
Alright, gimme this.
HEAGH - PUT IT IN ME! WAAGH!
-okay.
I'm also gonna need to upgrade some stuff at the mom- Shut up!
I don't care about the Argent Energy stuff that I just blooowed.
A'right *reads* faster recovery time
*deep breath*
multi-targetting
NEEagh let's not do that.
The shotgun's oddly enough my best thing, so...
I guuuueeeeesss
Yeeah, okay.
I might as well go for the mastery of this thing.
Ohhh, "get twenty direct hits on Imps"...?
Well that sounds pretty easy. There's plenty of Imps always throwing themselves at me.
I must be super attractive to Imps (not just Imps, look at the comments)
but that's a whole 'nother problem that I'mmana be dealing with later.
Cuz right NOW-
I probably shouldn't go down there
That's probably death.
But there's gotta be another way around that leads me to-
HOOP!
Yess.
Okay that's cool.
Hyah heh!
FUUCK!
Hep Hep!
A'right, pretty good.
Pretty good (x2).
Hap Hep!
Hap Hep! (x2)
Hep!
A'right, not bad, not bad.
I like it.
Gimme some mobility here,
Gimme some.. ability to go around.
Where did I see...
Now what is that?
What is that? (x2)
See, I- I don't know what that is, but I kinda wanna go find out...
Hop!
Hep yip!
Alright.
Up here somewheeere...
*quietly* Huuuh...
Oh! It's just- it's just here!
Oh! Okay, that's dumb..
Okay - well I'm dumb.
Hey! Cool!
Oh that's what that was! I didn't know that's what that was!
Or I would've spent a lot more time trying to find it.
Wow I am dyumb.
Okay... "route power to subsystem"
I didn't know health was a "subsystem", but I'm gonna try it anyway..
Hooray, I have more health now
I am less... death... susceptible.
I shoulda been getting those a longgg time ago
because I am just dumb if I wasn't..
*deep breath*
Ohhh I shouldn't ask that because of course the answer is "I am dumb and I can't get what I need to get"
but whatever, so
Carrying oooonn...
*slurring, higher pitched* CARRYING OOOONN
We're moving forward.
Hohbleah
Hooip!
Ooh!
Sure is nice to have more mobility,
but I wonder what's gonna try to stop me from being mobile
Probably everything.
C'mere, I need to do a direct hit on you.
WELL
That's not entirely-
oohhh
That guy is not gonna have fun getting up in the morning tomorrow.
Woop!
I assume it works out like, a lotta demons were..
They just get- they- they don't die.
That's a- that's a thing in like, demon lore,
especially in like, you know, popular culture,
especially, uh, like Warhammer 40K I believe does this thing where,
whenever you kill a demon, it doesn't die,
it just gets sent back to the demon world,
which is why the demon problem can never really be solved,
it can only really be just.. fought.
Which is an interesting way to think about it
and would be especially interesting if-
if the motivation for this guy was just to-
Woah, hello-
was to create, like, unlimited energy for mankind, then
it makes sense that tapping into hell might be the only way to properly do that.
Whoops.
Hep.
*sing song*
Thank you!
I have lots more health than I have in past.. so don't worry about it.
Oooh!
I think that was the direct hit that I needed.
Thank you, Sir!
..ir
Sir?
Sir? (x2)
Sir? (x3)
Siir? (x4)
Aaaand dead.
I kinda like this combo-weapon-function
because it reminds me a lot of "Painkiller"
Uh, if any of you guys've played Painkiller, it's a wonderful first person shooter,
like, phenomenal. The original. I don't know how m- they made a bunch of sequels
but I don't think they were ever as good as the first one.
*inhales*
*surprised* Secret found? What - this is a secret?
I didn't know that!
How was I 'sposed to know that?
I'm gonna get this for the plasma rifle
THANK YOU! Boink!
But, uh, the Painkiller
er, "the Painkiller"
*corrects self*
Painkiller was actually a really interesting game
because.. it provided, like,
a really interesting..
look into, uh...
senses of scale
like, scale in terms of both the size of some bosses,
but also the size.. of the battlefield
and the number of enemies that it would throw at you at once.
It is.. like, astonishing, even today.
If I went back and played it I would still really, really be interested in it..
In just how many different ways
*deep breath*
it could show me
ALL of the different crap that was there. And..
there's so much stuff in Painkiller to explore and secrets to be found
and just generally the run and gun gameplay.
I think when they were designing it, it was supposed to be reminiscent of the original DOOM.
I missed this, I just went back for it.
*manly voice* "Revenant" - That was the name, yeaaah.
(See? Told you.)
Okay..?
Didelee deedoo
*reading from screen*
*brainfart*
Huh!
*inhales*
*voice crack* Interesting.
I wanna know what this labsinnerous (Lazarus, Mark not words good does) wave is because-
Woah, hello.
*sing song*
Thank you~!
I needed to get that *burp?* direct hit anyway, so thanks for coming to me.
Saved me the trouble of goin' and finding you.
*high pitched* Boink!
Aww, not a direct hit? Mah, fuck.
*under breath* I wonder what's over there.
Is it worth goin' back all this way? Probably not.
But I'm gonna do it anyway because I'm a big dumb doofus.
I mean it kinda seems like there's something over here but I dunno if that's something that I can actually go into.
No!?
How 'bout above it- Aaah, fuck, a big wa- big waste of time for everybody involved - SOORRRY!
Ookaay...
*disappointed* Anyway...
Man, that is a big ass tower.
That's like the first time that I've actually taken a moment to look at it.
*under breath* Pretty impressive if you think about it.
I mean, the whole CONCEPT of harnessing energy
from..
hell..?
It's kind of an interesting concept and I don't know how they do it, but, uh,
i-if I had to guess, like the position of the lore
and the position of the sto-woahhh-
..the position of the story, this must be
- generally speaking - after the events of the first game,
but I don't know how far after the events.
OH GOD DAMMIT
Did I go- GOD DAMMIT. Aww, I went the wrong way. I-I think I backtracked a little.
But AH, FUCK ME
Heeep.
Oh no, I think I'm okay I just need to- I needed to drop off-
*ironically drops as he says those words*
WOOAAH, WAAH FUUUUCK!
I'm fine, don't panic. Everything's fiiine.
I just needed to go up heere
and jump off this.
Like a BADASS! Boink!
*sing song*
Thank you~!
*barely audible* Alright.
Who'da thunk that would be the proper way to go about these things? Too bad the pipeline exploded-
WAAAAH you! I'M COMING TO GET YOU!!
You better run...
[Dr. Samuel Hayden over helmet comms]
[VEGA over helmet comm]
Mark: Huh! Okay..
Well, about that...
What do we do? Do we kill her? Still?
Do we try to stop her? Is this like a citadel situation from.. uh, Half Life 2?
Where we're trying to climb to the top and then it's all gonna explode?
I mean, if this campaign is as long as they say- *gasps*
YYYYEEEEEESSSS *weapongasm*
[UAC spokesperson blabbering about- WHO CARES, SUPER SHOTGUN!]
[UAC spokesperson over P.A.]
Mark: How was that agreed upon?
And what is- what is this, right now, doing to everything else in the world?
Like, how in the world is this affecting everything else in the universe?
Because if I'm destroying the power source, that sounds baaaaaad.
[UAC spokesperson over P.A.]
Mark: Woooow.
Hello! - Boink!
Oh sorry, I need to do this one:
*high-pitched* BOINK!
*voice crack* There we go!
Okay..
*goofy voice* Eh! Zeboink! Hehe.
So that's fascinating. The whole idea that this is broadcast literally everyhwere
*really curious* Hooow? How is that possible?
*overly curious* HOOOW?
That's fascinating, I wanna know more about it, but I'm in the middle of blowing shit up.
Oh god, it's a summoner. Boink!
I'm gonna get you in just a second, summiny womminy - Boink!
And I - did I.. hit him?
I don't think I hit 'em.
Whoop! Got 'em that time!
*sarcastically* Ohhh nooo!
Ooop! He b- he blasted!
He got a blast!
Ooh shit.
Boink!
Did I get it- DAMMIT, not a direct hit?
Got a direct hit on that guy - OHH, that's quad damage!
That's quad damage! (x2)
Boink!
That's quad damage! (x3)
Hah! Quad damage! Bwam, bwitch!
Quad damage? Bwam, bwitch! (x2)
Quad damage?
Quad damage! (x2)
Quad damage! (x3)
Bwam, bitch!
Quad damage? (x4?)
Oh shit.
Quad damage (x5?)
Quad damage! (x6)
Quad.. (x6.5)
Damage! (x7)
Quad damage? (x8)
Where'd he go?
Where'd he go?? (x2)
Where'd he go??? (x3)
Stop- stop dancing.
Dammit, all my quad damage went away.
He missed out on all my quad damage.
Tudele-dudele-dudele-doink!
Thank you!
*condescending* Oh no, you're dead. Nice wings, LOSER.
Too bad you're DEAD.
Oh. Okay. One last dance before the end of the night.
Okay.. What do we got in here? Anybody wanna talk to me?
Huh, interesting... this seems fascinating.
I don't know any of this operates, but I'm pretty sure I'm gonna be able to blow it up.
Uuuuuuuuuh BOINK!
Okay, lemme just check the map real quick to make sure that I'm in the- *audible burp*
'Scuse me, sorry, rude! -make sure I'm in the right spot... what is this, automap?
*GASP* I need thaaat! I was close to that! Lemme go back and get that.
How did I miss that? Dammit.
If I wanna get any secrets, because apparently, the pulsating technique isn't working for me.
*inhales* AND I DON'T KNOW WHY
I'm very accepting of pulsations normally.
But this seems a little ridiculous that I can't even find where the secrets are.
Maybe I'm not paying attention to the right thing when it's pulsating...
I mean, WHAT IS the thing that's pulsating?
How am I supposed to know what pulsations I'm supposed to pay attention to?
*baaarely audible* I don't know...
*inhales*
Oh, there's something down there. How was I supposed to get down there?
Hmm, I'm gonna go get that.
[Holographics UAC spokesperson rudely interrupts]
Mark: SHUT UP!
Mmm Down here somewhere?
*British-ish accent* OH, HELLOW! Hi!
Oh, you died in an in- why are these guys dying in completely random places throughout the entire universe?
Like, this is just bizarre, that they would intentionally hide away
because they're 'sposed to be "elite soldiers" that are 'sposed to be "protecting" this shit.
*inhales*
AND YET, I don't think that's the case.
Oh well, whatever.
They're just trying to be like me.
I wonder if the experimentation on making these supersoldiers is kinda similar to
the experimentation that caused revenants to be made.
Uh, I have no idea if they made them here
I mean, I'm certain because of this weird energy source,
there had to be a lot of experimentation with it.
Including experiments on humans and seeing how they respond
because demonic possession is a big thing in this kuh- in this kinda universe.
So I would expect that there's something... to be said about it.
*BARELY audible* Come on...
I'm s- I-I'm just assuming that I'm supposed to be following this like this.
*sarcastic* Oh no I can never get back, oh nooo...
Alright...
Anything else here?
Wow...
*deeep breath*
Uuuuhm, okay...
Continue on, maybe?
Hello! Yes, another one, yes!
Thank you, I'll take that.
*quietly* Okay.. yeah...
Cuz, uh, one of these days, I'm gonna take a moment
to actually stop and read up-
*under breath* Oh I thought that was a.
Yeah, that is a thing.
Arge- ah, Argent Energy! That's exactly what I di- wanted to read up on.
Okay..
*reading text on screen*
"...a new and powerful substance that was discovered on Mars..."
Mark: demon... jizz..? o_O
*inhales*
Something.. or other...
Uuuuuhhhhhhh okay.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I wonder if that had anything to do with the original UAC
because UAC is the name of the original thing from the original DOOM
so I know it has to be related somehow.
Ouh, okay.
So what am I looking at over here?
Is this a battlefield? Am I gonna be fighting something biiig?
Please, yees, I would like that very much.
HELLO!
Ha-buschk! Anybody?
Anybody wanna get shoosted?
HOAAHHH!
I'm so stroaang!
Ooooh, this looks fun >:-)
CAN I BLOW THAT UP??
*high pitched and excited* Hiiii! Can I blow YOU up?
Mark: I hope so yees!
Facility Voice: Demonic presence at unsafe levels.
Mark: Oh you're telling me.
Facility Voice: Lockdown in effect.
Mark: Hoi-doi-doink!
Sorry buddy!
I don't even NEED to lock onto you-
WOAAH, that's- OW! Holy shit!
Didn't know that was gonna happen!
Woah!
I am in trooble (trouble)- AH!
Aww, come on!
Aaah shit, I saw health on the horizon, I wasn't able to get to it.
Okay - I didn't know that he had flamethrowers!
That's new!
*reads hint* "If an enemy has a head, it's a weak spot."
*sarcastically* OH, REALLY?
What enemy doesn't have a head, exactly?
Hep! Bokay!
Alright, this time I'm not playing around! You guys are gonna get
FUUUUUUDGED UP!
Oh, lemme do this:
THREE SHOT!
Okay
Hellow, buddy!
*many battle, much intense*
Uh-huh, take that, thank you!
Woah, hello!
Fuck, man.
Woah! Can I c- p- can I please, thank you.
Can I please?
Man, there are a lotta these things.
Woooaah, woah.
This is no joke!
This is no joke at all!
Woah! Woah! Woah! Woah!
Didn't know you were able to do that, holy hell!
Literally holy hell.
(Mark is a satanist confirmed)
Ohhh I see a quad damage!
Ohhh I see a quad damage! (x2)
Gimme de quad damage, baby!
Yuss! Where are they?
Where are they? (x2)
Where's my r- assault rifle.. thank you.
That's what I was looking for.
Thaat's more like it!
Thaaat's the stuff I like!
Okay, there we go, get that...
Quaad damage!
Quaad damage! (x2)
*sing song* Thank you~!
Alrigh.. boink!
Is there any more of 'em?
There you are!
Dammit, right after my quad damage runs out.
Haha-hahaha!
Mark: Okay.
Facility Voice: Demonic presence eliminated.
Mark: Yaaaay!
Facility Voice: Lockdown disengaged.
Mark: I did it! I'm the best!
Oh- move filter - I don't know what that diiid!
Okie-dokie then.
Whyyy did I do that?
Was that something that I actually needed to do
or is that just something that's helping me somewhere else?
*under breath* Wait..
Ohh, does that get me up higher?
That's probably what that does.
If I could've gotten up there, maybe.
I'm not 100% sure whaat I'm doing.
*cut*
Okay, so I'm supposed to climb up HERE
and then I imagine that's gonna get me higher and higher up on the tower
and I'm gonna be able to do what I need to do
which is 'kill *inhales* OLIVIA PIERCE'
Huah! Okay..
[to elevator] Take me higher!
... Eventually. Take your time, we're not in a hurry or anything.
*sarcastically?* The whole universe isn't about to explode in a horrible hellscape.
Naah, what are you talking about?
[VEGA over helmet comms]
Mark: Okay, that sounds important.
[Dr. Samuel Hayden over helmet comms]
Mark: Uh-huh, okay, tell me why I care.
I mean, I was locked away in a.. like, frickin stone tomb,
how am I supposed to be able to be concerned about this?
Oh NO, the door is closed! I can't just directly blow it up?
Ah shiet.
Well fine then, I'll find another way around.
HubadeHOOP!
I just seem to be running up as fast as I possibly can.
Awwww noo, baby, please!
Come on!
Be nice!
They're not gonna play nice, are they?
Oh, they are.
Alright.
HoobadeHOOP!
Hap!
Okay, we're up!
Oooh, another arena!
Yes please - POINK!
Boink!
Boink! (x2)
Boink! (x3)
Why is this guy not dying yet?
I forgot that the revenants are kinda tough.
[to demon] No.
What the - I'm out of all ammo?
What - really?? How am I out of ALL ammo?
Seems rather stupid.
Probably because I keep wasting it on s- dumb endeavours.
... that aren't actually gonna help me - Woah!
Wha- ow!
Ow - I am literally left with just the pistol.
I don't even have enough gas to be able to  take down the revenant with my shotgoan (shotgun).
Whoop!
This seems like - eh -  it's funny, this- this tower seems to be developed like an arena
in.. multiplayer.
Which is kinda cool, but at the same time, a little confusing.
Hyop!
*singing*
I need a-mmo bom bom bom-bom-bom.
What-the hell-is-that?
Oh shit.
Heeeyy hoooo - what the hell is this?
(invulnerability, noice)
Oh, that's convenient.
If I could combine that with like a berserker pack or somethin',
Insu- I know insufficient fuel! I've got insufficient everything.
Like I can't fight these guys, I don't have ammo.
Oh, there we go. I guess this is sumthin.
Please, thank you!
Woah! Goddamit! There's so many revenants around!
Aahhh tell Leo to baaack off brah.
Is there another quad damage around here or somethin'?
HURAAAAAHHHH! There you go.
Okay, that gives me some ammo. I always forget that I can do it to the little guys. Oh, well. Whatever.
Ow. That was not the weapon that I thought I had.
Heuupp Boink!
Mmm-kay.
*low health beeps* Mark: Ow!
Why?
Mark: Alright, got that, got that.
[Facility voice over P.A.]
Mark: Thank you!
I think some of the hell knights probably fought eachother because there was- that was a lot easier than I thought it was gonna be.
Apparently, for some reason.
Can I get up there now?
Can I jump on that thing? I'm assuming that everything with a greenlight attached to it means that I can climb upon it.
Straddle it and such.
No secrets up here? Okay!
[U.A.C spokesperson makes bad pun over P.A.]
Mark: Ummm, that's not a good slogan for the company.
Of all the ones that you wanna field test with like, focus groups and stuff, you probably wanna knock that down a few notches on the priority list because,
*inhales*
"The road to hell is paved with Argent energy," isn't exactly the thing that I want to hear every time that I think about what's powering my toaster.
Why would that be the thing?
[U.A.C. spokesperson repeats bad pun over P.A.]
Mark: Again, I just told you it's not a good slogan man, you need to come up with something new.
HUHbiscus! (???)
I didn't even see this on my mini map but it's cool that it's here.
I'm glad!!!
HUUHHBWUAAAH!
What I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna upgrade my uh,
I'm gonna upgrade my...
...armor. Because- OH! My ammo! Becaue I run low on ammo so much. I gotta upgrade that next.
But.. there's a lot of stuff that needs to be upgraded. I just need to find more of those things.
But I would've thought I would've had one on my mini map but I didn't *low voice* seeee it.
So there's gotta be another way up around *pitch goes up* here?? Maybe??
*pops lips*
Apparently not.
Huh.
*reading* "Elevator locked. Welcome to the U.A.C- " Okay.
Mark: Alright! So-
[U.A.C. spokesperson interjects bad pun once more]
Mark: AGAIN! I need you to shut up about that! I'm directly from hell so you can back off a few steps. So,
thank you everybody so much for watching! I'm all out of time for this episode here but I am having a blast.
Quite literally, and I'm getting slowly better at the game.
I think maybe I should be able to follow these guys up now that I activated the drones, but,
who knows?! We'll see about that. Maybe if I just stand on this guy.
Maybe he's gonna take me on a ride! The likes of which I have never seen before.
Yes? Please?
OOOooohhh!
Hey cool! I don't know what- Woahhh!
Bye Buddy!
WooooHhhh!
Okay!
Well, I was just about to end the episode.
Let's go a little- uh-anh!
Hep daak!
HUP DAAK!!
Okay, I'm gonna stay up here, so,
thank you everybody so much for watching! And in the next episode we'll take care of the Olivia problem.
But, thanks again, and as always, I will see YOU, in the next video! BUH BYE!